recently you had Elon who by the way I  think he's maybe the first major Captain  of industry to mock the ADL since the  adl's Inception that's the first it's a  major thing it's incredible and he  continued it so Israel did a tweet and  Elon kind of mocked them too and but but  in a playful way saying look  um you know we need more people to tweet  we need more countries to tweet and so  if countries are tweeting  um you know it's just it's too valuable  it's it's not like there's this other  thing called what is it called like  Triceratops there there's some stupid  like left-wing version of Twitter that  they're trying to do  you can't you can't do that because of  the network of things